jean-patrick
vous êtes tellement star qu'on va vous
faire l'interview cire pompes
[Applaudissements]
patrick poivre d'arvor vous effectué un
parcours sans faute une carrière
impeccable que pouvez vous espérer de
mieux essayer d'écrire des
chefs-d'oeuvre par exemple formidable
alors dans l'univers de la télévision
vous êtes devenu parfaitement
indispensable qui pourrait présenter le
journal de 20 heures sur tf1 par vous
thierry ardisson moi j'ai fait religieux
ppda de la culture l'année prochaine sur
paris
il paraît que c'est un rêve de
travailler avec vous c'est vrai un
défaut un défaut d un peu j'ai une
impatience évidemment a toujours obtenir
les choses telles que je les veux donc
parfois je suis vis-à-vis de mes
collaborateurs et comme j'ai beaucoup de
collaboratrices jésus parfois un peu
soupe au lait et je m'en veux toujours
beaucoup parce que je trouve qu'il ya
rien de pire que les gens qui se venge
sur les gens qui en principe
ne peuvent pas répondre en foutant une
bonne paire de baffes que je mériterai
de temps en temps c'est vrai que j'avais
un charisme extraordinaire quand même
temps oui oui
surtout par an 10 ans
vous êtes terriblement sexy comment
faites-vous pour résister à toutes ces
sollicitations féminine toute la journée
patrick jeu je me bouche les yeux je ne
regarde rien j'avance je pense qu'à mon
travail je suis là comme un petit cheval
dans la tempête je me dis surtout ne les
regardais rien voir que le travail de
travail travail de roger
[Applaudissements]
cette timidité que vous montrer parfois
quand on parle de vous vous donne un
charme fou vous en êtes conscient
mais c'est vrai que je vais profondément
je suis je suis timide donc c'est très
difficile de décider parce que ça alors
y'a des gens qui masque sa part
l'arrogance a c'est vrai et en fait son
ultime interet rentrée mais évidemment
se venge et bi moi quand je rentre pour
vous dire la vérité quand je rentre dans
cette atrium laval ce décorum un machin
c'est près 13 grecque qui vous regarde
et que difficile et alors qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire alors c'est que la
fouée tout petit il faut être humble et
donc peut-être ça donnait un petit bouc
charme je sais pas mais c'est pas long
terme pour vous dire moi je souhaite
parfois rentrer sous la moquette voilà
vous avez une voix très craquante alors
si si et squeeze on va tous fermez les
yeux vous aussi karen tout le public va
fermer les yeux et patrick vous allez
dire très doucement très calmement comme
ça je vous aime comme si on était la
femme de votre vie en vous écoute je
vous aime
et
ça c'est énorme on va le sample est
comme ça qu'on va se passer de temps en
temps le soir à la maison alors patrick
tout paris bruisse de vos exploits vous
êtes champions de toutes les disciplines
celle du corps comme celle de l'âme et
en plus c'est drôle comment vous faites
tue pas drôle du tout
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu